[Music]
the great thing about therapy and
especially with addiction therapy was
just the 12 steps
you know the 12 steps
they work for every sort of addiction be
it drugs alcohol
sex
all these things and it starts with like
serenity prayer which has
helped me to accept the things
that i can't change and the courage to
change the things i can
and the wisdom to know the difference
okay
but you have to understand men
especially in my world
you live life as if you're in a revenge
movie
i'm i'm laughing because i i i i'm a lot
smaller than you are but i understand
you don't want me i get it i get it hey
movies like that man like payback and
death wish and oh wrath of man i mean
this is a long list right oh wrath of
man taking
this thing where you get on the phone
and you tell the guy i'm gonna hunt you
down
i'm gonna take you and your crew out one
by one
and you're gonna die slow you know it's
like man on fire also a good one
and you make them pay
for everything you make them pay for
everything they ever did to you
that's the male fantasy it's better than
sex
you know what i mean like tim it's like
oh my god you can literally sit in the
theater like man
oh that feels good
but this is the problem
tim this is the problem man i found out
and this is so crazy you can either have
success
or revenge
but you can't have both
it blew my mind
and
when you're talking about getting
revenge
this is why i even alluded to the the 12
steps was because
revenge is trying to control things you
can't control
you know what i mean it's literally like
you've lost it
and now you just gotta even the score
you know
most of us are all about settling scores
you know
but
the thing is the score scores never
really settled
things just get worse things tend to
fall apart i bring up incidents where
the things where i i used violence
i was the kind of guy i even start my
book out where i talk about how i beat
this man up on the street man for
disrespecting my wife
and this was in pasadena this was around
oh i would say 2008 2009
and this guy
he basically talked disrespectfully to
my wife
and she was just like whatever but i put
this dude out i mean
literally put his head on the concrete
and the police came
and it was a big hullabaloo man and i
the only way
i got out of it was because there was a
guy in the crowd who was like no no no
you know
i saw the whole thing officer
this guy came up there and they were
bothering them too and the whole thing
so i got away with it
but it was way out of
it was way too big a reaction for what
was done
but that was me selling my scores here's
the revenge movie you know
and my wife pulled me to the side and we
went home and she said terry
she said you have to promise me
promise me
that you will never ever do anything
like that again
and i was like what i mean you need to
be protected and she said wait a minute
she said i got this
but you
are going to lose everything
you have
you said you're going to get sued you're
going to get shot and injured or you may
be killed
by someone who you go up against on the
wrong day or a police officer
you know like you can't go around
and putting people on their head like
this
until i was just like
i was like no i don't i i i said i got
to this is this is my thing this is me
being a man this is what this is about
this is me being tough
and she said no terry she said you got
to promise me promise me
and i said okay
all right i promise i promise and i
don't even think i meant it
you know at the time
but
i made a promise to her that i was gonna
gonna take the the righteous path and be
less violent you know and not or
non-violent and try to
handle things in a non-violent way and
little did i know in the future it would
actually save my life
in so many ways so
many ways and
and what i mean is is by
not choosing revenge because that's what
that is
is when you put somebody on it you know
the whole thing is a little bit like
you playing chess and you don't know the
right right move so you turn over the
board
that was my answer for everything
you know what i mean like i'm stuck on a
move
instead of thinking my way out of it my
answer was just turn everything over
yeah that was my answer for everything
and it led me to a very very hollow
existence
so there i was in therapy trying to
figure my life out
and trying to control the things that i
couldn't control because you can't
control people
you can't control what people say to you
and a lot has been said about even
my friend chris rock and my friend will
smith and what just happened at the
academy awards right and i there was a
time when i was will smith
but what saved me
was when i was the time i was chris roth
and it didn't descend into chaos
i decided to what you would call take an
l for one day
but actually win the whole war
the other thing in therapy i discovered
is when you can have the courage to
change the things you can
and let me tell you this
there was some because of victimology i
had given up control on probably every
aspect of my life
i it was
it was always up to somebody else
even where i where i worked what i did
it was always someone else's decision
and then i found out i had a lot more
power than i realized i was like if i
just work on me
if i stop pointing at everyone else
and i just put 100 percent
into improving myself
all of a sudden things started to change
tim
i have to tell you man
that first year was really really hard
coming out of therapy and i mean i was
there in and out for a while we would do
it by phone we would go back in it was a
place called psychological counseling
services in phoenix and
and they had dealt with a lot of people
who had a guy who had really lost
everything because of these kind of
addictions
and it was really it was wild because i
thought can i change
i was getting triggered every five
minutes it's like
i don't know but what was happening is
as i continued to work on myself i began
to change
i changed i slowly but surely
started to see things
the way i needed to see them you know
and what's so crazy about belief
is when you believe you're different
you slowly start to become different you
have to believe it first you know what i
mean
you